hallucination is a sensation without a
stimulus but why the hallucinations
occur to answer that we have to look at
perception itself we think of perception
as a passive process an input arrives
and is received but actually perception
is more like a guess of what is out
there in our environment it's the result
of sensory input and sure but also
another component that may be just as
important our prior beliefs or
expectations some scientists think that
hallucinations occur when strong beliefs
create an imbalance with sensory input
to see if they could witness this
overpowering of external input by
beliefs researchers created a game that
caused auditory hallucinations and
observed the effects on brains and
behavior their experiment is a twist on
Pavlovian training whereas Pavlov's dog
learned to associate food with sound
instead the scientists trained human
players to associate sight with sound in
the game a checkerboard flashes on and a
tone is played simultaneously with
enough repetitions participants start to
expect to hear the sound when they see
the image even when the sound is it
actually played they were played the
tone at different intensities and
sometimes no tone at all as the game
went on there were more and more no tone
events the participants were asked to
press a button each time they heard the
tone they were also told to press longer
based on their confidence in their
judgement when players were presented a
checkerboard without the tone but still
pressed the button that was considered a
hallucination
four different groups were selected to
play a control group that didn't have a
history of hallucinations or psychosis
daily hallucinate errs with no diagnosed
psychotic illness non hallucinate errs
with psychotic illness and finally daily
hallucinate
with a psychotic illness crunching the
data researchers found that all
participants experience condition
hallucinations during the game the
people who already heard voices were the
most susceptible to the effect and were
the most confident they heard tones when
none were actually played brain scans
conducted during the game showed what
regions were activated when condition
hallucinations occurred researchers then
devised a model for hallucination that
provided different weights for beliefs
and inputs fitting the behavioral data
into the model they found that
hallucinate errs due overweight beliefs
and this correlates with regions of the
brain that we know relate to perceptual
beliefs those with psychosis were less
able to update their beliefs which
correspond with activity in the
hippocampus and cerebellum which
typically guide our memories and our
sensory and motor predictions about our
bodies in the world the model suggests
that when players without psychosis were
trained in the game
they formed a strong belief that the
sound would coincide with the
checkerboard but as the game progressed
they caught on that more no tone trials
were being played because they were able
to update their beliefs the players with
psychosis on the other hand had trouble
adapting as the game changed
[Music]
the next steps are to use larger sample
sizes and machine learning tactics to
further distinguish between voice
hearers with and without psychosis the
hope is that researchers could diagnose
if a hallucinate er is on a path to
psychosis and suggest more targeted
treatments in the future
[Music]